-Congratulations on
your Grammy nomination.
Now, you've been
nominated for Grammys before.
This is the first time that
it has not been a collaboration.
-Right. I was nominated with
Pink.
I was nominated with
Mac McAnally, Grace Potter,
and some other people.
But this is the first time that
I've been nominated for
something solely that I created.
-That's very exciting.
Congratulations.
What was the
difference this time?
You've obviously had a lot of
solo work over the years.
-I think we just did
a lot of things that was
left of center than how
we usually release a record.
I had a single.
Then we changed it.
I had an album title,
and we changed it.
"Cosmic Hallelujah"
wasn't even the album title.
-What was it before?
-I can't even remember.
-Well, that means
you made the right choice.
-Yeah, right.
[ Laughter ]
So, we did a lot of
interesting things.
I made a video for a song
that we knew that
wasn't gonna be a single,
called "Rich and Miserable."
-"Rich and Miserable."
-And my friend John McGinley,
who's a wonderful actor --
-Wonderful actor.
"Scrubs" and "Platoon."
-He played
this college professor
at Columbia University
here in New York.
and just did a brilliant job.
And it was --
You know, sometimes,
record labels don't like it when
you go and make a video
on a song that's really
expensive, when they know
it's not gonna be
a single on the radio.
But we did it anyway.
And I think that
it was things like that
that really allowed us
to dig a little deeper
than you normally do on a record
when you just traditionally
release the singles
and do the marketing plan.
It was chaos from the beginning.
And I felt like that, somehow,
it's worked out in the end.
-Well, that's fantastic.
You mentioned that
you shot this at college.
Your first song -- Is it true
you wrote your
first song in college?
-I did.
-And what led you
to write your first song?
-I was in -- Ironically enough,
I was in a persuasion class.
-Okay. I feel like they
don't have those anymore.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
But there was
a girl sitting next to me
that I was trying to persuade
to go out with me.
-Oh, wow.
-And so I thought that
I would write her a song.
-Very persuasive.
-And so I stayed up
in my apartment off campus
and I tried to write
this girl a song.
And it was -- Some of you
may know what a cassette is.
You probably still remember
what a cassette is.
I put it down on a cassette.
You know, you had to hit
the play and record
at the same time?
-Uh-huh.
-And, so, I did that
with my guitar
and I took it
to class the next day.
And she sat
right beside me in class.
And I slid it to her.
Didn't say anything,
didn't even look at her.
All right? I just went...
So, you know, class ends.
I go home.
I come back the next day.
And she was, like --
Remember, she was sitting
right here at this table.
And I walked into
class the next day,
and she was sitting in
the far corner of the class.
So, that --
-That's amazing that you
persuaded her to move.
-Well, it was my -- Yeah, I did.
-Yeah.
-But it was literally
my first taste of
rejection in the music business.
-Well, that's good.
It certainly
turned around for you.
Now I want to talk
about the fans.
Kenny Chesney fans refer to
themselves as "No Shoes Nation."
But you have fans
that travel for your shows.
You obviously want them to
have a good experience.
Is it true that when you --
'Cause you play big --
You play arenas.
You play football stadiums.
That you go sit in
the worst seat
before the show starts just
so you have a sense of
exactly the gap?
-Right. We get there
on a Friday,
and if we're playing
a Saturday stadium show,
we get there and do
sound check on Friday night.
And I will go --
Just because I want to
emotionally, visually,
and mentally measure
how far I have to go
when I'm onstage
to reach the people in the very
top of that football stadium.
And unless I go up there
and sit and absorb it all,
I don't really know.
Now, I know what it looks like
from the stage up there,
but I have to visually see
what it looks like
from up there down here.
And that's why I do it.
And that's one of
the things that I do,
because I tell you, Seth --
the connection we have
out there onstage
is the most unbelievable thing
I've ever felt in my life.
And we have people --
Like you said,
we have people that travel.
We have people that
really care about the music.
And, you know, we've been
doing this for a little while.
And that relationship with them
has been built so strongly
over the years,
and I'm very proud of them.
And it's one of the reasons that
we're able to do what we do.
-Well, that's fantastic
that you do that.
I want to talk about another --
a place you have
a connection with,
which is the Virgin Islands.
You had a house in St. John's.
-I did.
-And after the hurricane,
you were one of
the first planes
to go down there to help out.
You started a charitable
organization.
Can you tell us
a little bit about it?
-I started a foundation called
Love for Love City.
And Love City is
the nickname of St. John.
And that place,
the Virgin Islands,
the BVIs and U.S. V.I.,
has been a place
that has really fed me,
as an individual,
over the years.
It's fed me as a human.
It's been a huge part
of my adult life
and it has been a really big
source of creativeness.
It's fed me creatively.
It's fed me
emotionally and mentally.
It's been a healer.
It's been
so many things in my life.
And when that happened, to --
I wasn't there the night
the storm happened,
but I was home
and I was watching it,
like the rest of the world.
And to see that storm cell go
right over the island,
and I could know
where my house is.
And I had 17 people inside my
house, going through the storm.
And that was the most anxiety
I'd ever felt in my life.
It really was.
And I knew then that
I was going to do something
to help the island,
to help the people.
And we started
Love for Love City,
and it's been an unbelievable
thing to be a part of.
-That was you
heading down there, right?
-That's right.
-There you go.
-And, so, I had an
island dog named Cookie.
-Uh-huh.
And Cookie -- We had to bring
Cookie back after the storm.
And I've got
this assistant named Jill.
And Jill loves dogs.
And Cookie died in Jill's arms
at my house in Tennessee.
It had only been off
the island never, until then.
And that's why you see
what you see there.
That's when I decided that
we were not only going to try to
help the people on the island,
we were gonna help
the dogs and the animals,
because they were
as displaced as anyone else.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's fantastic.
That's really great
that you did that.